God of War three was released in 2010
and honestly since then I don't believe
that games have really changed that much
looking at the generation before it from
the ps2 to the ps3 there was a huge leap
in terms of quality of content and the
way that games played out and what the
systems could handle since then I think
the changes have sort of been
superficial many of the the games that
were released on the ps4 within the last
two or three years I believe could have
been released on the ps3 and there isn't
that much difference except from on a
graphical level and so I thought I'd go
back to this what many consider a
classic and God of War three and see if
it still holds up today and if it is as
good as many people said that it was
back then and so starting off the story
I'll note was when playing through this
is very thin and it becomes over can
overcome volute with the the Pandora
storyline eventually she saw the way she
ties in and this plot seems a bit
pointless and by the end it's sort of
for nothing and there's gonna be huge
spoilers in this review so I recommend
that you if you want to play the game
fresh then you know where the hell have
you been for the last eight years or so
but you know turn this off for hit
subscribe and so it's revealed in the
box that there was nothing so the entire
game that you've been playing through in
order to get this box it's been a
complete waste of time really and which
you know it's it's quite sour and you go
into a massive force walk in section as
well at the end of the game which seems
really counterintuitive especially when
God of War to the ending of that the
last 90 minutes of it just kept ramping
up and ramping up and there was fight
after fight and you were constantly on
the edge of your seat with it where is
this it's it's quite downtrodden and
it's strange how games have sort of
become a lot like that like Arkham
Knight is very downtrodden towards the
end the Last of Us is
a lot of games now sort of prefer to end
their their game on an anticlimax in a
story section rather than a boss fight
so it's quite interesting to go back and
see where it sort of began in this game
and it's not very well executed here
though so I didn't particularly enjoy it
and you know the the cliche ending of
the hero kills himself and then after
credits you see the body's not really
there that's sort of but obviously you
know that had to be done to play into
what's gonna be coming out next year
hopefully God of War for I found with
the game itself if you level up properly
very early on then most of the fights
become an absolute dawdle even on hard I
never understood in God of War ascension
there was the section where I remember
people complain that the difficulty
spike was so massive and it was like oh
no no gun can ever pass this and they
actually had a release of patch and to
correct the difficulty on that and make
it slightly easier I'm a bit of a
warrior so when I hear games are
difficult I think oh you know kind of
can I even go through this can I be
bothered anyway I got in that section in
God war ascension got through it first
time didn't even realize hadn't had the
patch and I was like what was that why
everyone's talking about their bit of
mobs them and so yeah it's it's weird
how you know games have sort of release
patches now where they sort of cater to
their audience whereas back in the day
of like the the Super Nintendo and stuff
you got a game that was hard in the if
you didn't complete it they're like yeah
so do you make you're not completing
there and whereas now I think a lot of
artists they put so much time into these
later sections in the game they really
want you to level up and there's
absolutely brilliant brilliant abuzz
fights like the Cronus one here this is
outstanding even today it definitely
stands out as the highlight in the
entire God of War series the fact that
there's such a significant feeling of
scale like you you you go to where
you're up basically on this massive
level that's a moving creature
and the camera zooms in like you can see
at the moment at this moment yeah you
fully pulled out you've seen the full
scope of the character and then you zoom
right into like the tiniest section on
them and come flying out and you're just
basically an ant on them and it's still
so impressive today and I really do not
know how they managed to pull this off
and I kind of wish more games had
sections like these because it is really
thrilling to fight a massive boss you
know it's very superficial but it's just
the feeling of power that you get from
kicking the crap out of someone who's a
million times your size there's great
puzzles in this um but you know there's
a lot of parts that take place in the
dark where you've got a walk around dark
corridors and you can't really see what
you go in and you have to stop lights to
fight stop lights to fight and it's it
just slows the pace a bit in the combat
because of it really suffers um so I
didn't really like those sections and I
think they've aged very poorly a lot of
the combos in this game as well or just
square square triangle if you just keep
hitting the square square triangle
you'll get through every fight and it's
a shame that the clicks cameras sort of
don't allow you to see a lot of the
things that you're fighting and a lot of
the times you'll be hitting things off
screen and just kind of guessing where
they are and because of that the combat
doesn't feel as defined as it should do
a lot of people including myself used to
praise God of War for how good the
combat was it really influenced a lot of
games but then the arkham combat came
out and that was sort of the step above
and it's sort of the industry standard
at the moment and going back to this it
feels a bit strange and because of it
it's it's quite difficult to get into
the fighting as I once had being into it
and obviously this is a game made up of
fighting you pretty much get our [ __ ]
from kill room to kill room there's a
bit where
you're flying through a level and then
you land in a kill room and you have to
fight these like monsters and honestly
if you'd landed like 5 foot in front you
wouldn't have had to fight them and you
would have just went on the next
objective so it really feels like
they're just padding out the game
especially towards the end there's so
many mind-numbing fight and it just
becomes a slog especially when you don't
know what you hit in most of the time
and it's just wave after wave of villain
that you've fought throughout and you
just really want to progress with the
story last night I knew I was coming
towards the end of the game so I thought
ah I've been on two hours I'll just stay
for another 15 minutes because I think
that's all the game has anyway I was
there another two hours because it was
just there was so much just padding of
fighting boss a crappy little boss after
boss and it just got it just got mind
them and after a while and it really
takes the enjoyment out of the game for
you and because of that it actually
sours the ending and it's just yeah
there's certain things in it that you
know really don't hold up and it's
really unfortunate there's lots of
backtracking and you go up and down that
mountain several times you like bloody
Brian Blessed going up and down that
mountain yeah you having that one that
brilliant Joe and there's weird bits in
the plot like Pandora there's a bit
where she really panics and she's like
oh my god Susan's coming and you can
hear you can hear the chicken oh my god
Susan's coming blues tower
come rescue me Chris and you get there
and it's just fine and they do that
several times and it's just to make them
feel a sense of urgency but there's no
point in doing it and you've got
terrible moments like this where the
graphics really take a dip on the ps4 I
don't know why it looks so badly
textured because it looked okay on that
on the ps3 and so yeah there's just a
couple of janky bits that really haven't
held up overall though do I feel like
this is worth playing if you want if you
never have and you gotten to god of and
you want to get in the car
for try and pick up the M remasters of
God of War one and two because two is
one of my favorite games of all time and
it really is it I still think it holds
up and that will give you really good
demonstration of whether you want to get
into this world and but for everyone who
wants to play God of War three I don't
massively recommend going back to it and
that's why I'm giving it a 7 out of 10
so what do you think in the game comment
below let me know and I'll see you next
time take care